when you look at footage or photographs
of astronauts in space it doesn't look
like there's any gravity at work here
the everything is not falling and down
in one direction in fact it's not even
clear what up or down is everything just
floats around if I were to push off of
this wall I would just float in that
direction so it does it look like
there's this there's this overarching
influence like gravity that's trying to
pull everything down but the question is
is that these astronauts are still not
too far away from a supermassive body in
fact the Space Shuttle Space Shuttle
gets up a cup only a couple of hundred
miles above the surface of the earth so
the Space Shuttle if I were to draw it
to scale would probably be right about
there and we know we know that the force
of gravity between two objects is equal
to big G the gravitational constant
times the mass of the first object times
the mass of the second object over the
distance between the two objects squared
and if the Space Shuttle is right here
only a few hundred miles above the
surface of the earth this R isn't that
difference it's a little bit low it's a
little bit further than if you were at
the surface of the earth remember that R
is measured from wherever you are to the
center from the center of the earth or
really the center of the object to the
center of the earth the center of the
the earth represents most of the
distance here so if I'm at the surface
of the earth or if I'm just a few
hundred miles above the surface of the
earth it's not going to change our that
dramatically especially in terms of
percentage so when you look at it this
way it seems pretty clear that the force
of gravity for someone who is in in
space only a few hundred miles above the
earth should not be that different than
the force of gravity for someone who is
on the surface of the earth so my
question to you is what gives if there
should be gravity in space how can we
see all these pictures of people
floating around like this and the answer
is is that there is gravity in space and
that these people actually are falling
they're just moving fast enough relative
to the earth that they keep missing it
and let me show you what I'm talking
about there so if I were to take a
if I were to if I were to let's say I'm
sitting here in Africa and I were to
shoot something if maybe I have a really
good slingshot and I were to sling
something super fast at maybe a 45
degree angle
it might take off a little bit and
eventually hit another point and this
would actually already be a super-duper
slingshot I just made it travel a couple
of thousand miles or at least over a
thousand miles if I make it go a little
bit faster if I put a little bit more
force on if I just propel the projectile
a little bit faster I'll it might go a
little bit further but it'll eventually
fall back to the earth let's try to
propel it a little bit faster than that
then it'll still fall to the earth let's
propel it even faster than that well
then it's still eventually going to
follow the earth I think you might see
where this is going let's go even faster
than that so if we go even faster than
that eventually it'll fall to the earth
even faster than that so if you if you
were to throw an object even faster than
that it would then go really far and
then follow the earth but I think you
see what's happening every time you go
faster and faster you you throw this
projectile faster and faster gets
further and further up to some some
velocity that you release this
projectile and every time and whenever
it's trying to fall to the earth
it's going so fast that it keeps missing
the earth so it'll keep going round and
round and round the earth and a
projectile like that would essentially
be in orbit so what's happening is if
there was no gravity for that projectile
if there was no gravity the projectile
would just would just go straight at
good to go straight away into space but
because there's gravity it's constantly
pulling it towards the center of the
earth or the center of that projectile
and the center of the earth are being
pulled towards each other I guess is a
better way to think about it the force
of gravity is doing that and so it's
curving its path and if it's going fast
enough if the if the projectile or
whatever object we're talking about is
going fast enough it'll just keep going
round and round the earth and since
there is almost pretty much for for most
purposes no air at if you go high enough
especially the altitude that the Space
Shuttle at is no noticeable drag
this thing can just keep on going for a
substantial amount of time although
there is just a little bit of drag and
that's why over time you do have
satellites slowed down because there is
just a little bit of air resistance so
the answer to this conundrum is that
there actually is gravity it's not it's
not a gravity-free environment it's just
that the astronauts and the space
shuttle and everything else that's in
the space shuttle it's all falling but
it's moving fast enough that it never
hits the earth it keeps missing the
earth it keeps it keeps going round and
round and round but it is completely
under the influence of gravity if they
were to just slow themselves down if
they were to just break relative to the
earth and if they were to just you know
they put their their brakes on right
over there they would all just plummet
to the earth so there's nothing special
about going three or four hundred miles
up into space that all of a sudden
gravity disappears the influence of
gravity actually on some level it just
keeps going you can't it might become
unnoticeably small at some point but
definitely for only a couple hundred
miles up in the air there is definitely
gravity there it's just there in orbit
there going fast enough so if they just
keep falling they're never going to hit
the earth and if you want to simulate
gravity and this is actually how NASA
does simulate gravity is that they will
put people in a plane and they call it
the vomit rocket because it's known to
make people sick and they'll make them
go in a projectile motion so if this is
the ground in a projectile path or a
parabolic path I should say so the plane
will take off and it will it will do a
it will do a path exactly the same as
something in freefall or in a parabolic
path and so anyone who's sitting in that
plane will experience freefall so if
you've ever been in if you've ever you
know right when you jump off of it if
you if you've ever bungee jumped or sky
dived or even the the feeling when a
roller coaster is going right over the
top and it's just pulling you down and
your stomach feels a little ill that
feeling of freefall that's the exact
same feeling that these astronauts feel
because they're in a constant state of
freefall but that is an
indistinguishable feeling from if you
were just in deep space and you weren't
anywhere close any No
a mass that is that is an identical
feeling that you would feel to having no
gravity gravitational force around you
so hopefully that clarifies things a
little bit to someone who is just
sitting in the Space Shuttle and if they
had no windows there's no way of them
knowing whether they are close to a
massive object and they're just in
freefall around it they're in orbit or
whether they're just completely far away
from any massive object and they really
are in a state of or in a place where
there's very little gravity